il est le premier suédois à soulever le
trophée sur l'open de france alexander
noren 35 ans a réussi à dompter le
parcours de l'albatros avec un score de
67 finale alors qu'il était parti avec
un déficit de sept courts début de
journée sa dixième victoire chez les
professionnels
c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de francesco
molinari à wentworth quand vous êtes si
proche vous voulez vraiment cette
victoire
et c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir aujourd'hui est si alexander
noren l'a emporté c'est aussi parce que
les autres cadors présent qu'elle est
l'espagnol john rabe a dû se contenter
d'une cinquième place son compatriote
sergio garcia terminé 8e à égalité avec
le numéro deux mondiale justin thomass
l'américain était surtout venu pour
prendre ses repères sur l'albatros avant
la ryder cup en septembre prochain
c'est un bel endroit c'est un super
parcours une superbe ville et j'ai
vraiment aimé venir ici cette semaine du
côté des tricolores on attendait le
numéro un français alexander levy le
chouchou du public français
ce dernier terminera finalement une
décevante 65e place au classement
seul michael lorenzo-vera arrive à se
hisser dans le top 20 en terminant 16e
position avec une carte de 68 le
dimanche c'est toujours bon
très bon j'ai pas non plus fini très
très haut je pense que c'est pas une
truc à retenir par rapport aux autres
français
je pense que le monde sait que se bat
pour faire mieux que que le top 20 si
les français n'ont pas su saisir leur
chance avec cette victoire sur le futur
parcours de la ryder cup le suédois
alexander noren pourrait définitivement
convaincre le staff de le prendre dans
l'équipe européenne
réponse au plus tard le 12 septembre
[Applaudissements]